hot breath bo johnson's question who
asks um what was the first
joke beth wrote
well i think i've told this before my
hair is getting
it's getting blurred out yeah yeah thank
goodness yeah
[Music]
and i put on a ton of makeup okay
getting gussied up for this thank you
okay truthfully i want to say
like joke wise well because
because i was i've always been a mix of
stories and jokes
um so i'm trying to think of like some
of the earliest
jokes i guess like i've been flying
since i was six because my parents are
divorced
now first like joke i first and i've
said this before sorry
because like i've been asked these some
of these questions before no offense
and it's just one of these two we're
gonna get deeper here it's just the
first two
it's okay keep posting questions don't
mind her everyone
it's like geez what shallow questions my
fans are asking right now
that's actually that actually harkens
back to my initial issue
of when i watch sarah and she makes it
new every time i have a huge problem
with feeling
disingenuous which like like
so sometimes my stand up if i've
performed the joke for a while
i almost start to tell it like you guys
know this one and it's like no they
don't and it's not because i think
everyone knows me or is familiar with me
it's because i know how many times i
told it and so i'm kind of like
i get weird saying it again and i kind
of throw it away
so it's like stop doing that like
do it like you just wrote it for them as
opposed to like so i feel disingenuous
and the reason i say
what i just said is i've said this
before too in an interview but
first joke was uh we would drive to my
grandma's in louisville
and there was a sign
for this you know exit called nameless
creek
and i said to my mom i was like what is
that one that lewis and clark didn't get
to
you know i think that was probably my
first like
put some see something put it together
make something and then
inadvertent joke was probably first
grade and my mom asked like did you have
a sub today
and i said no you packed me a peanut
butter and jelly
so like you know when a kid is just like
doesn't
that was probably my first inadvertent
joke um
but then like when it came to stand up
my jokes at that time were very like
i remember you know your references are
i get i haven't had a chicken soup for
the soul joke i'm trying to think of
like early jokes
air tran i had i had airplane jokes
about sitting have to you have to pay
extra to sit
in the exit row i didn't sign up to be a
flight attendant i
have no clue this is a bad answer can we
every answer has been great beth okay
and that
that actually is something we as
comedians struggle with a lot in terms
of
not giving rambling answers but
um is to actually
it's actually that making your joke new
every time
and delivering it the same way every
single time like what if
what mindset do you go into the joke
with or have you found a system or
ritual that helps you to actually
deliver it
like it is the first time i still
struggle
i still struggle i have to you know i
don't want to go back to the same club a
year later and
give the same act and i i don't
this problem and anxiety of mine has
resulted in probably more material
because i'm scared like you know i've
had people kind of come up to me like
every time i see you it's different and
i'm like
to me i'm like it doesn't feel like that
but i'm so glad you're saying that
because i'm terrified of showing up to a
club every year
and being the person who's like same
jokes
every time yeah well simult
everything's a tornado in my head hot
and cold fronts
meeting because you're like you don't
want to be the comic
that does that but you also don't want
to be the comic that just shows up with
weak ass material and it's just like
throws out here what do you guys want to
talk about it's like
you know be professional show up